or jean d'ormesson quand je vais inviter
dans bad minuit vous m'avez dit pourquoi
m'inviter vous oui vous dire pourquoi
parce que vous respirez la gaieté vous
avez des yeux qui pétillent quelle
chance la seule chose que je pourrais
vous reprocher ses dettes vous êtes
parent avec le peletier de saint-fargeau
quand même quitte un régicide
ah oui j'étais très fier je ne renie
rien à part mais justement je vais
demander je faisais pas rond d'harward
quelqu'un qui a voté la mandoline c'est
ce que lui aurait été assassinée
quelques jours il a été assassiné pour
au palais royal à peu près là où elles
resteront véfour maintenant dans un
restaurant qui s'appelait février si je
me rappelle bien
il ya eu il ya une malchance il est
tombé sur un gars du roi il s'appelait
parisse et le barde du roi évidemment
l'avait rencontrée plusieurs fois à
versailles puisque il était l'entourage
de louis saez et malgré ça puisqu'il
était conventionnelle et qu'il était
aussi un ami dans l'espère je vais
aborder la mort au nom je sens qu'elle a
voté la mort du roi
bon moi je ne pense pas que j'aurais
voté la mort du roi et surtout pas voté
la mort de la reine
il avait vingt années du règne de louis
saez été l'apogée de la france
écoutez je ne sais pas si vous
connaissez est-ce que lisez mon frère
400 à l'académie gaxotte disait
supposons que louis saez du soit mort en
1880 4584 1785
si c est bien la révolution aurait eu
lieu tout de même et tous les historiens
dirai quel malheur qu'il soit mort si
lui avait vécu et tiendrait bien la
révolution leurs épaules lieu où elle se
serait bien passé alors vous voyez je
crois que c'est tout à fait vrai vous ne
pensez pas des rois libéral pour tout à
fait sous son règne que des droits de
l'homme ont été proclamés vous ne pensez
pas vous faites partie d'une espèce en
voie de disparition il ya des gens qui
travaillent beaucoup mais qui donne
toujours comme ça l'impression d'une
certaine facilité
2 c'est toujours à l'aise je vous ai vus
arriver tout à l'heure vous êtes à
l'aise vous entretenez avec tout le
monde
vous êtes star dans les dîners en ville
parce que c'est brillant et cultivé
pensais pas que des gens que vous il ya
de moins en moins je travaille beaucoup
je suis sûr vous travaillez
j'ai longtemps fait croire que je ne
travaillais pas beaucoup maintenant
c'est presque difficile de faire croire
que je ne travaille pas beaucoup parce
qu'on ne voit plus beaucoup dans les
dîners en ville dans les cocktails
parce que je travaille et le week-end le
samedi ou dimanche évidemment je
travaille je suis pas si les résultats
sont à la hauteur du travail mais en
tout cas je travaille
il fera un petit reproche donc dire que
louis pauwels il faisait moins bien que
vous mais ces articles sont pas mal
écrit le corbeau ils sont très très très
très bien ces articles sont pas bien
écrit je trouve que c'est un peu moins
bien que vos livres vous donner autant
de mal que lui pour faire vos papiers du
figaro magazine
je ne sais pas en tout cas c'est vrai
que j'ai fait de mon mieux
ouais mais c'est vrai que j'attache plus
important support tony huit nouveaux
articles quand on lui en parle et 10
mois chaque semaine je suis une page de
livre dans le figaro magazine
c'est alors que vous bon sang c'est un
peu plus cet accord est un peu plus les
affaires doit faire un effort par les
systèmes permettent aux aléas georges
tâche at il dit quand vous êtes super
brillant
nul n'en disconvient mais on se demande
finalement cela de votre brillante vd
les conditions avant profonde présence
est catholique
je suis catholique
le pape a condamné l'apartheid vous le
savez le tacle est ce que vous faites
entre la situation en afrique du sud
je situe la secte rempart tél qu'est ce
que vous faites contre l'apartheid
je vous dis à d'abord j'ai joué bien que
ça commençait un peu trop bien joli ça
va vous avez tout à fait raison
alors je dois vous dire que quand j'ai
été nommé directeur du figaro est une
des acteurs et yao raymond aron a fait
un petit discours en trois points où il
ya du dabo pardonnez moi il est d'abord
il est très intelligent voter pour lui
deuxièmement il est d'une ignorance
encyclopédie tapas tard on nous avait
tous voté pour lui
et troisièmement et c'est ce que je dis
il ya des convictions très ferme mais
extrêmement vague c'est très commode
voter pour lui j'ai été alors c'est vrai
que je ne suis pas militant je ne suis
pas un militant
je suis un militant pour certaines
causes que je crois je me disais juste
par exemple pour la majorité actuelle
que contre le contre l'apartheid et fort
je pouvais pas me dire son fait des
papiers par exemple
d'abord j'ai d'abord
jenny lee avec l'unesco un endroit les
nations unies qui ont condamné le plus
fermement l'apartheid donc je ne suis
pas suspect de défendre apartheid
ensuite je crois qu'il ya un peu
d'hypocrisie dans les affaires
l'apartheid
si on veut rompre avec les régimes dont
on ne partage pas les opinions et je ne
partage pas l'opinion régnant en afrique
du sud
je ne partage pas non plus celle ci
règne en russie
et si on rompt avec l'afrique du sud
ce que je comprends très bien qu'une
demande ce qu'on attend pour contre avec
l'iran et pourront qui nous a fait plus
de mal que peuvent attendre avec on
m'appelle je me suis prononcé très très
vivement contre pinochet je ne suis pas
pour pinochet
je ne suis pas pour l'afrique du sud je
ne suis pas pour la région de
soviétiques et bien que je vive avec eux
et je trouve que ce qui s'est passé ces
jours ci c'est à dire le refus des
polonais du référendum
jarden ce qui est quelque chose de
stupéfiant car j'attendais ce qui leur a
dit est-ce que vous approuvez les
réformes démocratiques
est-ce que vous approuvez que je vous
donne un peu plus de liberté et les
polonais ont répondu non c'est un peu
pareil sur le racisme le pape à
condamner le racisme
qu'est ce qui nous fait contre la chute
l'a fait contre le racisme vous faites
quoi
je sais quoi ce que chateaubriand lui
lave et la duchesse de berry se désole
du mal à l'ailé à prague je vais vous
dire ce que je fais pendant le figaro
magazine rue où vous approuvez beaucoup
mon ami pour elle ce que nous avons
aussi beaucoup et bien je suis un des
rares à m élevé avec autant de force
contre le père si vous trouvez que c'est
pas quelque chose qui se beurre de
s'élever contre le pen dans le figaro
magazine
et bien maintenant tout le monde le fait
mais j'ai même reçu pas mal de lettres
de lecteurs trouvant que je t'ai dans le
figaro magazine
bières et bouffe vous tombez amoureux
d'une petite bird une beurette moi oui
si elle si elle me plaisait oui sans
aucun doute
je vois pas de même dans l'ombre le
problème je crois aussi que je les écris
et que j'ai écrit que si ma fille tombée
amoureuse d'un noir et ben je serais
tout à fait à chanter qu'elle épouse à
condition naturellement qu'ils tiennent
président de la république qui soit
frank sinatra bien parce qu'il faut pas
être vous aider la même troupe bullard
vous avez un les plans aussi son
annulation
alors voilà il faut prendre ce qu'il ya
de mieux partout et naturellement que
l'ombre de différence entre un blanc un
jaune et un loi c'est quand même une
différence entre ajourné un blanche
contre les autres sont plus intelligents
pardonnez moi d'être raciste mais je
crains que les jaunes soit plus
intelligent qui est blanc vous avez
écrit quelque chose mais qui m'a
beaucoup touché parce que je pensais un
peu la même chose samedi
si un jour je me retrouve en prison ce
sera génial parce que moi je pourrais
écrire des livres à condition
naturellement comme on traite bien qu'on
m'envoie qu'on m'envoie comment vous
l'appelez une beurette où il a un petit
peu raide comme en voit une beurette et
qu'on traite bien j'ai un bon lit que
j'ai trois manches et que mais à
l'esprit moi j'en était enchanté dix ans
à la bastille vous faire chef-d'oeuvre
vous savez ces rayons des toujours
chantal mackay et tétouan mais moi j'ai
un scoop 6 heures monsieur damas ans oui
il est fan de baffie ah bon il adore
tout ce que fait ma fille qui trouve sa
fin
si jamais grossier n'ont pas bien
profond mais non ils adorent ça
il vous le dira pas allés voter me
regarder non mais si seras tu n'es pas
ils feraient sondeurs me son show oui
mais il se retient
ah non comme ça ça se retient forcément
j'aurais peut-être dû me retenir aussi
non je crois je pense chantal ladesou
celui que je vais recevoir maintenant
est un trésor vivant une espèce en voie
de disparition
un homme du xviiie siècle d'une culture
incroyable qui manie aussi bien la
langue parlée que la langue écrite voici
jean d'ormesson
bonsoir
c'est pas du sadisme nous avons remis
tous les deux à côté j'ai l'air un peu
plus grand que vous mais bon ça se voit
moins quand on est assis ça soit cinq
ans on était si vous avez bien on est
très heureux de rien ça va pas trop
troublé non mais l'asie tout à l'heure
un petit peu quand même
on m'a non mais on est très contents de
vous avoir surtout tout alors vas-y
beaucoup de bien de vous on a dit que
j'étais intelligent tout le temps parce
que nous on disait qu'avec des mots
étaient quand même un peu bête mais vous
tout le temps visés que des trucs
intelligents on va voir ça reste vous
êtes dans votre phase bardot dans votre
phase garbo alors j'explique à vos amis
téléspectateurs jean d'ormesson il ya
deux positions s'est soigné dans sa
phase bardot qui alimentera la
télévision soit notre surface garbo
série reste planqué chez lui là vous
êtes plutôt en ce moment je vous ai vu
sur une autre chaîne audio êtes plus en
votre foi de bardos non limite limite à
c'est bientôt la fin ça passe bardot de
la fin vous connaissez saisie car elle
m'a dit ok représentant de commerce et
lexomil linda hardy qui se ronge les
ongles parce qu'elle connaît pas le
lexomil et michel noir qui est beaucoup
plus marrant depuis qu'il a arrêté la
politique
alors jean d'ormesson vous avez déclaré
que vous avez déclaré c'est sûrement
mais vous ça pourrait être de vous
j'ai connu toutes les formes de
déchéance y compris le succès s'est
voulu très bien ça vous caractérise très
bien et vous vous avez dit en revanche
les honneurs je les méprise mais je ne
déteste pas forcément ce que je méprise
je trouve que c'est ces deux phrases
vous définissent à la perfection je
pense qu'une bonne façon de débarrasser
les à leur céder à voir oui on pense moi
que si on les apporte alors vous êtes
écrivain il ya un livre qui s'appelle
qui est là qui s'appelle le rapport
gabriel dont on va parler tout à l'heure
voilà je montre à la caméra comment
faire la td michel noir je suis bien
donc écrivent à leur accorder à ces
journalistes
mais si enfin c'est pas aussi important
c'est pas aussi important il fait dans
l'autre la phrase de gîtes qui disait en
faire que des citations se fait dans le
sens il parle que le parti était bon le
journalisme c'est ce qui sera moins
intéressant demain qu'aujourd'hui soit
c'est vrai je pense à bah oui c'est pour
ça que vous écrivez des livres oui
académiciens l'académie sert à rester
beau hiver vous avez dit vous ai fait
aussi des grosses têtes de rtl
et alors vous jouer dans le prochain
film de jean luc godard et bien oui en
principe oui mais c'est une somme que le
tournage est sans cesse reportée
avant ça devait déjà avoir lieu la
semaine dernière ça a été encore
reportée alors peut-être qu'on ne verra
pas dans ces trous noirs
jean luc godard enfin franchement jean
d'ormesson ou le film et font profiter
bien non mais il vous a écrit ce bel
éloge de l'amour le film ah oui vous
avez crise n'est pas reconnue se situe
comment j'ai reçu une lettre et g j'ai
eu mal lu sa signature j'ai cru que
c'était une dame qui m'écrivait et je
lui ai répondu madame on verra ça dans
un an
il m'a téléphoné en me disant c'est la
première fois qu'on l'appelait madame
est là donc après quand vous avez vous à
rappeler dans quel but vous avez déclaré
on ne refuse pas un fils d'un
financement alors juste pas à filer bel
et bien sûr alors on a parlé un petit
peu du rapport gabriel en 86 donc bien
avant d'écrire le rapport gabriel vous
aviez déclaré je crois qu'il ya un dieu
mais je n'en suis pas sûr car il ne
s'est jamais donné la peine d'engager la
conversation avec moi mais ça a changé
maintenant c'est fait puisque dans ce
livre dieu qui est en colère convoque
l'ange gabriel que vous appelez caby 007
et qui lui donne une mission c'est celle
d'aller demander aux hommes de
s'expliquer sur les désordres de
l'histoire donc l'ange gabriel va sur
terre et page 123 la rencontre jean
d'ormesson qui est en train de faire
trempette dans la méditerranée il vous
demande de raconter votre vie pour
écrire un rapport pour dieu c'est ça
voilà vingt dieu dieu est mécontent du
est mécontent des hommes vous savez il a
été déjà d'autres fois il a été
mécontent au moment du déluge il a bien
essayé de détruire le monde avec les
juges qui étaient d'ailleurs partiale en
faveur des poissons comme vous savez
c'est un racisme propose évidemment
et alors il avait abandonné à ce moment
là et maintenant il est encore plus
mécontent une trouve que ça va plus mal
je trouve que n'est pas content et alors
le donner une dernière chance aux hommes
et et il envoie gabriel qui est déjà
descendu plusieurs fois qui a rencontré
abraham qui a rencontré la vierge marie
qui a rencontré ma mère puis cette fois
là il tombe sur moi
il a vaincu soudan faire l'ange gabriel
viens sur terre sur qui tombe d'ormesson
bien sûr qu'on allait en faire en faire
il ya un truc excellent j'ai pas
évidemment je vais pas citer tout le
bouquin parce que si on n'est pas là
pour ça simplement dire aux gens de le
lire mais page 356 c'est un truc très
rigolo qui résume bien le bouquin parce
que c'est juste c'est quand même
vachement bien vous dites vous raconter
à l'engin une bonne partie du dernier
siècle s'est déroulée sous le signe des
jumeaux sanglant hitler et staline
ennemi mortel à lier entre eux par la
faiblesse et la faute des démocraties
libérales et là où c'est vraiment génial
le drame de mon époque c'est qu'il
fallait choisir entre eux oui je crois
que c'est un an
résumé du xxème siècle qui est
extraordinaire c'est que tout le drame
du 20e siècle
c'est tout les gens se sont crus obligés
d'être obligé de choisir entre hitler et
staline alors c'était la même chose
évidemment il fallait choisir entre eux
est évidemment s'est retrouvé dans le
même camp que staline et je crois qu'il
fallait se retrouver dans un staline
n'avait pas le choix il ya la peste et
le choléra et il faut choisir entre eux
et toutefois on ne peut pas être neutre
en tous les cas c'est une fois que 13
inscriptions bien sûr c'est une belle
description du 20e siècle on parlait du
pouvoir vous dire je n'ai pas aimé le
pouvoir car sa prétention me fait rire
quand j'entends vous avez exercé le
pouvoir
j'aime pas pour recevoir des ordres
ouais mais je n'aime pas beaucoup non
plus en donner donc il vaut mieux que je
m'abstienne de ce genre d'activité et
j'ai été j'ai été j'ai dirigé un journal
mais un journal je la veux particulier
parce qu'on ne donne pas vraiment dedans
mais je n'aime pas beaucoup les formes
de pouvoir c'est vrai j'aime pas le
subir et je n'aime pas beaucoup
l'exercer je sais pas l'éloge vous savez
il faut bien qu'ils aient des gens qui
exercent je n'ai aucun jeu n'est pas du
tout de dédain pour les les gens qui
exercent le pouvoir simplement moi je ne
suis pas je n'en suis pas friand voilà
alors en fait vous avez eu quand même du
pouvoir aussi parce qu'il y avait une
certaine culpabilité chez vous de ne pas
avoir su garder le château de famille
bien sûr pourquoi est ce qu'on écrit des
livres parce qu'on a des chocs
sentimentaux à l'oreille ou 1
pourquoi est ce qu'on écrit des chansons
pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait du théâtre
pourquoi est ce qu on fait du cinéma
pourquoi est-ce qu'on peint parce qu'on
a eu le choc sentimentaux choc
sentimentaux on les connaît mais il peut
y avoir les différentes espèces et
perdre une maison parce qu'on n'est pas
capable de la garde et c'est aussi un
choc sans qu on a tout de suite c'est à
vous qui parle
nous on n'existe plus à mon avis le plus
marqué les très jolies césium je vois
bien vous êtes un peu jaloux à vous mais
non vous avez vous avez déclarez vous
avez déclaré les premiers les premiers
livres on les écrit toujours pour plaire
aux filles
oui inscrit au nom non dites moi si
j'étais une remarque je suis pas gêné
moi je vais écouter bas j'avais aussi
papier montherlant qui a dit il ya
l'amour il allait vivre il n'y a rien
donc voilà oui c'est vrai je crois que l
amour les livrets et voilà pardon moi je
suis et dans l'amour dans les livres
mais n'avait rien de ce côté là ça va
vas-y vous ne trouvez pas craquant jean
d'ormesson l'esprit est ce qu'il ya de
plus séduisant
je veux dire un truc quand même il a
déclaré une de mes plus grandes passions
étaient pour une femme de 15 ans mon
aîné aujourd'hui avec des femmes de 15
ans de plus c'est un peu difficile il 15
ans nous a précisé le musée
ma mère
de vous rencontrer vraiment très jolie
veuve rêve devant vous savez le le coup
le plus classique qu'on me fait ces
jouets arrivée les jeunes filles
ravissantes qui pour faire dédicacer un
livre est la phrase classique était ma
mère a tellement d'admiration pour toi
et puis ça a changé il ya quelques temps
et c'est ma grand-mère et l'on doit
jeter chez gallimard et je raconte cette
histoire et à ce moment là y'a une
stagiaire qui entre ravissante charmant
et je vous assure qu elle a dit je crois
que vous êtes un ami devant le gardien
vous avez déclaré le matin un bon
d'accord vous aider si j'avais dît si
vous faites beaucoup de citations
ah ben moi c'est nul autre que soi quand
je me cite attendait si jamais tu es une
femme j'aurais aimé mener les hommes en
bourrique
vous auriez été le font pas je vais vous
dire je suis très favorable aux femmes
oui vous emmener en bourrique les femmes
oui comment que je vous croyais oui
comment
je ne crois pas quand on vous avez été
un bourreau des coeurs si vous saviez si
seulement je vous racontais un mois
michel vous racontez nous votre histoire
d'amour alors ma pire histoire d'âme le
pire la plus triste que vous la raconter
tout de suite allé un jour je suis
invitée avec greta garbo
on est trop à table et me j'admirais
beaucoup quant à darbo et prix d'une
espèce de folie je me met à chantonner
le pinphone coop fistful of reading est
ce que ça dit quelque chose je suis de
les pieds à la tête
oui et c'est la chanson de l'ange bleu
ouais je sais comment la mélodie voilà
un type il fut belle je chante sa great
à gogo l amour est à vous êtes comme on
insiste quand on fait des gaffes et j'ai
dit j'ai tellement aimé l'ange bleu
derrière j'ai dit je vous ai tellement
admirée dans l'ange bleu elle se
retourne vers moi et me dit je vois que
vous me prenez pour marlène dit à ces
maladies
plus tard je dîne à côté de malindi
vraiment on s'entend bien on s'entend
vraiment bien et elle me dit même ce qui
était assez rare elle me dit venez me
voir
j'habite avenue montaigne je crois
qu'elle habitait vraiment au top et je
lui dis je vais vous raconter une
histoire tordantes
je lui raconte cette histoire elle m'a
tourné le dos elle m'appelait donc
chance avec alors là maintenant on
arrive à on arrive à la géologie vous en
parler parce que je sais bien qu'on en a
beaucoup parlé mais enfin quand même
chaud que je vous en parlais métaux
courants
donc ça tombe un jour c'est pas vous me
regardez là j'ai regardé tous 357
qu'est-ce qui viennent qu'est ce qui dit
d'ormesson page 65 entre l'amont donc
jean d'ormesson prendre un petit
déjeuner avec françois mitterrand
le jour de la passation de pouvoir ce
que doit être le 17 mai 95 tchèque ils
papotent tous les deux comme ça
gentiment il parle de la sphère bousquet
et mitterrand lui dit cette phrase qui a
fait dont on parle depuis la sortie de
vie malheureusement pas là on a parlé un
peu trop de ça c'est pour ça qu avant
j'ai voulu quand même dire que niveau de
choses dans le livre et mitterrand dit à
jean d'ormesson dont vous constatez la
part d'alpha bousquet l'influencent
puissante et nocive du lobby juif en
france voilà alors après de gaulle qui
avait dit que les juifs étaient un
peuple sûr de lui et dominateur vous
souvenez de ça il va un dessin de steam
dans l'express qui est extraordinaire où
il y avait un type qui est derrière des
barbelés dans un camp de concentration
il y avait il avait remis la france
était une violente ces types qui a fait
ça et là donc françois mitterrand dit ça
on peut pas penser que vous auriez crise
à si c'était pas vrai parce que de toute
façon personne ne pense plus que les
femmes non d'autant plus le pense le
tirage d'autant plus qu'il l'a dit à
plusieurs faire savoir à attendre
la même chose en plus qui l'avait vu le
procès qu'on a fait on m'a dit il
fallait pas le répéter
oui pas vous pas comme ça pas maintenant
ouais et alors évidemment - moi c'est
mon droit le plus strict surtout qu'il
ne m'avait pas du tout demandé le secret
alors je ne vois pas en quoi vous
connaissant même temps c'est le répéter
vous savez j'ai même cru de bonne foi
qu'il me l'avait dit pour que je le
répète je ne crois plus maintenant je
pense que quand on lui parlait de
bousquet celle l'exaspéraient et qui la
laisse et il y avait de quoi est il a
laissé échapper sa alors lui un certain
nombre de réactions il urgeait alain qui
a dit que je tiens crétins ridicule oui
tu l'appliquer en communauté française
n'est pas très partagées non plus même
en france le giro qu'un deal n'a pu se
retenir de faire dans sa culotte
oui pas très sympa non plus jack lang
plus violents il a dit on utilise
parfois l'autre pour exprimer ses
propres sentiments serbe
c'est assez rare il ya aussi jean daniel
le patron du nouvel obs qui a dit
d'ailleurs françois mitterrand lui avait
dit à jean daniel vous me corriger si je
me trompe
tout se passe en somme comme si ce lobby
dont on parle existait vraiment donc
appartement ou jean daniel qui va
soupçonner d'être de droite jacques
attali fourbe 6 à 10 plusieurs
interlocuteurs m'ont rapporté ce type de
propos cela explique mes distances avec
mitterrand alors qu'en fait il a pris
ses distances pour partir à la berd
vous savez j'ai été d'une discrétion
exquise enfin façon de parler seconde à
60 55
parce que avant avant de d'entrée cette
formule je n'en parle pas d'un livre
mitterrand avait passé en revue avec moi
comme spectateurs muets le personnel
politique est alors il avait été surtout
sauvage sauvage avec les gens de son
bord et moi vous me connaissez très
courtois très bien élevé je le disais
vous savez ce mon côté sont pas fort non
plus oui oui mais sur le crétin mais les
miens
comment c'est à dire le fond et ring
alors si j'étais allé à la télévision ou
à la radio
et si jamais nous y voilà ce qui m'a dit
de untel untel je le dis à jamais mais
vous savez paris aurait sauté alors
voyez j'ai été très très modéré
jean-christophe mitterrand lui
effectivement il a alors lui il a
approuvé son père jean christophe
mitterrand cette course a rappelé la
mois non il a dit quand le monde a titré
mitterrand et d'antisémite et il le
monde fait partie de ces caisses de
résonance de certains monde pourquoi pas
d'un certain lobby juif donc le fils de
mitterrand vous ce que vous dites c'est
que personne n'a mis en doute vos propos
de toute façon personne ne met en doute
et maintenant j'accueille
[Musique]
jean d'ormesson mélanie mercier
jeudi jean d'ormesson jeu 10 en or me
sens une connerie le comte jean bruneau
vladimir françois de paule lefebvre
d'ormesson
génial jean d'ormesson vous voulez
toujours dans votre vieux coupé mercedes
oui lanvin fait toujours pour vous
spécialement son ou de lanvin oui voilà
c'est tout le sens et je suis suisse n'a
jean d'ormesson j'adore jean d'ormesson
je le dis franchement et tout de suite
vous incarnez pour moi une espèce de
france est en voie de disparition
malheureusement je crains d'être
moi-même bientôt en voie de disparition
par les pas de malheur non non non j'ai
connu toutes les formes de déchéance y
compris le succès c'est pas une belle
phase les honneurs je les méprise mais
je ne déteste pas forcément ce que je
méprise
voilà ça c'est du jean d'ormesson c'est
un peu comme la place il ya une phrase
pas de qui elle est tout avoir pour
pouvoir tout mépriser ces kiss et barrès
ou péguy ou un truc comme ça non bref
barrès alors que publié c'est comment on
fait un ou publics et si robert laffont
un livre qui s'appelle voyez comment
dans ce mail blessures
allez avec c'est bien assez
c'est la version chic sa version meubles
bien alors entrer dans la danse
ça vient d'une chanson entrer dans la
danse voyez comme on danse chante et
danse et embrassez qui vous voudrez
c'est cette espèce de gaieté déjà tout
de suite dès le titre synthes de
fraîcheur alors vous vous refusez une
époque où tout le monde est dans
l'accablement houellebecq tient dans une
époque où le bonheur est mal vu vous
refusez tout ça les jérémiades refusé
écoutez je pense que si j'occupe une
place peut-être ta par contre c'est pas
dû à mon talent mais peut-être parce que
j'essaye de donner un peu de bonheur aux
gens qui me voient là alors on sait bien
que on sait bien que la vie n'est pas
gay tous les jours je crois que puisque
vous avez la bonté de citer des phrases
de moi je crois que j'ai dit quelque
part que la vie était une fête en larmes
et ce livre là aussi c'est une fête en
larmes quand dans les bouquins on sent
que vous amusez beaucoup avaient peint
des personnages à raconter des destins
imaginer des intrigues on sent un vrai
plaisir d'écriture est au centre du
dispositif votre obsession pour le temps
finalement c'est un peu le personnage
qui revient dans tous vos livres
d'abord est-ce que c'est un plaisir
d'écrire je dirais que c'est très
difficile
je dirais que c'est à la fois un bonheur
et une souffrance lui il ya des pages
que j'ai recommencé 18 fois ah oui oui
vous êtes très bien oui c'est vrai je
crois que ce qu'il put difficile c'est
de donner l'impression de facilité est
alors sur l'autre point vous avez
absolument raison je pense que le
personnage principal du livre c'est le
temps oui c'est le temps qui passe qui
m'a toujours un peu obsédé comme ça
c'est pas le seul gérer un prédécesseur
qui s'appelait prou ce que c'est et
coûtait beaucoup aussi
est ce que c'est le temps qui passe ou
nous qui passons peut-être que le temps
est immobile et c'est nous qui passons
oui non pas le temps malade et nous nous
en allons d'ailleurs vous avez changé de
coiffure
alors que vous en penser les gens
parlant de choses sérieuses
comment un couple est aussi très bien
mais c'est un vrai succès ce truc là on
s'en branle un climat la télé par
exemple ça fait moins jean pierre
foucault etc et je veux qu'ils veulent
alors vous mêlez très bien la grande et
la petite histoire et des sites crps est
un roman total c'est une ambition tout à
fait louable et très moderne en même
temps vous savez il ya un film dont
quelques-uns d'entre vous ont vu qui
s'appelle la comtesse aux pieds nus
ouais alors au début il ya un vagabond
serment bossi et puis un très beau gars
qui est là et il revoit tout ce qui
s'est passé alors le lu le livre en un
mot se passe en trois heures dans un
cimetière et à propos de tous les gens
qui passent en même temps on part en
chine en amérique du sud en inde et le
siècle entier voilà ça commence par un
enterrement on enterre romain qu'on
pourrait résumer en disant qu'il vivait
avec talent c'est un ami du narrateur
qui est le grand ordonnateur de ses
funérailles et une amitié finalement
comme celle qui lie deux personnes qui
ont aimé la même femme puisque tous les
deux le narrateur et celui commentaire
on aimait marina des belles séances à
patmos je vais vous dire ce livre est
aussi un c'est aussi une histoire
d'amour
ouais et alors j'avais écrit jadis à un
livre qui s'appelle vent du soir où il y
avait quatre soeurs et là il y a sommé
de faire une mère et une fille - et
alors autant de set mais elle c'est
fillon ya des hommes qui tourne alors
vers la mer ces mecs tignon qu'on
appelle la reine margot donc est une
collectionneuse de marie damman et
parler ses amants elle a eu lucky
luciano le chef de la mafia new yorkaise
et c'est lui qui a organisé en partie le
débarquement américain en sicile du fond
de sa prison et ses les aventures
formule est alors le piano a tué
naturellement comme on ne sait pas s'il
a tué son prédécesseur mais son
prédécesseur était italien aussi et pour
le tuer on disait les ceux qui voulaient
le tuer luciano se disait c'est pas
possible de prendre des gangsters
italien parce qu'il connaît tous les
gangsters
mais on a pensé aux gangsters juifs qui
ne connaissaient pas mais alors il ya
une autre difficulté c'est que le
meurtre avait été fixée un samedi
parce que le samedi les gens étaient en
week end et la garde des témoins sérieux
mais les gosses juifs au lit le jour de
sa mort sont créateurs pointus par le
jour du shabbat
alors on a dû changer la date on l'a
fait à mercredi ça s'est bien passé
la fille c'est marina dont qui a été
aimée effectivement à la fois par le
narrateur est un romain celui
commentaires ya bessire donc un musulman
qui fait la guerre dans la wehrmacht et
dont hitler empreinte l'homme poursuit
signer alors là tout est vrai aussi
hitler c'est vraiment suicidé avec un
valter 7,65 je crois alors vous dire que
béchir c'est bon là peut-être qu'à un
tout petit coup de pouce alors tout le
xxème siècle y passent un à travers des
souvenirs croiser des différents
personnages
vous m'avez dit dans tout le monde en
parle finalement le 20e siècle a eu à
choisir vous souvenez de ça entre deux
tragédies entre deux monstres le nazisme
et le stalinisme
est ce qu'aujourd'hui finalement s'en
était débarrassé est ce qu'aujourd'hui
à l'aube du xxième siècle on voit pas
arriver encore un totalitarisme c'est
non pas encore une fois le fait d'être
musulman mais le fait d'être
fondamentalistes et le fait de lire bien
sûr je pense que vous savez le 11
septembre il ya quelque chose qui s'est
terminée et quelque chose qui a commencé
et nous ne savons pas exactement quoi
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya tout un pôle
histoire qui est tombée en arrière je
pense que ce qui s'est passé ce qui est
terminée on sait ce qui est terminée
mais c'est comme c'est comme la
déclaration de guerre de 14
c'est comme pearl harbour c'est comme la
chute du mur de berlin il ya un monde
nouveau qui commence où elle devait
jouer a réagi un mot là qu'ils ont
pressé que je suis ardemment contre le
terrorisme intégriste et je ne mélange
pas l'islam et le terrorisme survenu
vendredi au sénat du regard
et déjà sûrs de vous entendre dire parce
qu'on la vie en commençant cette
émission tout à l'heure avec ma fille et
jamel est la pire chose qu'on pourrait
faire c'est de jeter l'islam dans les
bras du fondamentalisme il faut faire le
contraire voilà il faut isoler les
terroristes et les toros peut venir de
partout
vous savez que il ya eu un terroriste
qui s'appelle ah beh oui abbas georges
habache que j'étais chrétien alors il
faut isoler météo risque et tâcher de
regagner tout tout tout tout tout ceux
qui sont contre tout efforts ne faudrait
pas on peut dire à la télévision il
faudrait pas qu'en france ce soit le
début d'un racisme anti arabe parce que
encore une fois ça serait ce qui
pourrait arriver
dieu nous en garde mais je te jure ce
qui me fait le plus mal au coeur et qui
m'a le plus mois touché ce qui me fait
le plus peur propres pour l'avenir c'est
l' amalgame que quand on risque de faire
dans les rues je sais que que ça va que
l'enfer commence pour nous vraiment j'ai
ce sentiment là j'ai peur qu'on m'a dit
sur quoi c'est pour ça que jean
d'ormesson du sein c'est le défi de la
démocratie la démocratie ne peut pas
employer elle même les méthodes qu'elle
condamne absolument pas
et donc il faut que la démocratie soit à
la fois forte et respectueuse des autres
alors vous êtes académicien français oui
alors évidemment je vous faire une
interview proust express c'est ce que
tout le monde croit juste une interview
de bernard pivot mais en fait c'est le
questionnaire de proust
simplement je vais vous demander c'est
très important de répondre en faisant
des fautes de français comme vous et
académicien en faisant des fautes de
français au bois sans rien n'est plus
facile droit par exemple si je vous dis
vous fait couper les cheveux tous les
combien vous me répondez je vais au
coiffeur une fois par mois d'accord
d'accord je dois faire une fois le mois
on ne bouge pas
en bouche pendant le seigneur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien vous êtes prêts toujours bien alors
quel est pour vous le comble dans bien
quel est pour vous le comble de la
misère le compte de la misère oui alors
c'est les fautes et les faux jeu
qu'aussi bien ouais je qu'aussi bien
mais voulait souffler si vous voulez et
les mois mais je suis sûr vous parlez
très très bien alors le compte de la
misère traité que allez-y c'était que et
puis là vous n'êtes pas là il va vous
aider si beau que ça doit bien qui fait
un effort conciliant alors le compte de
la misère
le comble de la misère c'est de sasp et
et que les grecs
bg sa mère la main vous traitez que
baiser sa mère des huit jean d'ormesson
votre idéal de bonheur terrestre mais
reprendre ça serait démarrer un roman
démarre et 1re manche la faute pour
laquelle vous avez le plus d'indulgence
les gens qui causent pas bien votre
qualité préféré chez l'homme
de par le dialogue c'est quand ils sont
et l'académie de voir enfin remy ce sera
un exemple bien sûr alors il faut pas ça
lui en rouge
la voilà votre qualité préféré chez la
femme le bij hocini misogynie le palais
je vous ai mises par exemple à quelques
préfets la femme c'est camus c'est
qu'elles plaisent bien
c'est dieu pour vous de faire des fautes
oui si du principal défaut facile ça
cette cause est tellement bien ce que
vous détestez par dessus tout la musique
qu'il faudra la rue le don de la nature
que vous aimeriez avoir
la rapidité par exemple
france un peu épuisé moi c'est tellement
non j'ai très bien c'est très bien
j'aimerais j'aimerais j'aimerais être
comme vous à mon âge jean d'ormesson de
l'académie française et messieurs
à mon sens c'est moi
et maintenant avec le temps avec le
temps va tout s'en va
voici jean d'ormesson
[Applaudissements]
jean d'ormesson
[Musique]
istanbul est passible impasse at elle
ajouté non
[Applaudissements]
j'en ai désolé il peut pas m'embrasser
sur la bouche parce qu'il est
académicien
enfin je peux vous remplacez vous avez
lu alors j'ai reçu un mail après votre
dernier passage dans l'émission un mail
de arnaud salomon qui a 25 ans et qui
habite à lille et qui dit juste pour
dire qu'en voyant jean d'ormesson
ça donne vraiment envie de devenir
académicien sosa je sais sincèrement
voilà alors publié un livre qu'il
voulait appeler adieu donc voilà en fait
seul hésité entre adieu les carottes
sont cuites il va faire est dans le sac
ou et voilà le travail voilà le travail
c'est pas mal et finalement donc ça
s'appelle c'était bien et c'est chez
gallimard mesdames messieurs
[Musique]
voilà c'était bien alors c'est pas un
roman c'est pas des mémoires c'est pas
un essai c'est quoi un truc assez un
truc pas à vous auriez dû le marquer à
la place il reste un truc on sait parce
que sinon c'est pas les mémoires non bah
non c'est pas un essai parce qu'on me
dit le quoi parlez vous j'avais très
peur que vous me disiez de quoi parlez
vous sinon c'est très compliqué ce thème
elle fait une espèce de d'état des lieux
un voile avant de convenir ça comment
comment ça va voilà comment ça va alors
pendant que j'explique comment ça va
j'explique aussi aux lecteurs comment
lui va voilà à peu près voilà alors le
pitch finalement c'est votre vie le
pitch à l'académie ce mot je compte sur
vous pour que le mot pitt se rendre dans
le dictionnaire de langue française
alors je n'ai pas encore fait entre à
l'académie je les fais entrer chez
gallimard et je leur ai dit je vais vous
expliquer le pitch le pic et personne
chez gallimard on savait ce que vous les
lieux le alors j'ai dit mais comment
vous n'écoutez pas ardisson lui en faire
et alors
et à l'intention de ceux qui font les
études je leur ai même dit par exemple
quel est le pitch de phèdre et bien le
puits qui te fait c'est une dame est
amoureuse de son beau fils
malheureusement le beau fils est victime
d'un accident de la circulation voilà
voilà le pitch préfère c'est quoi une
puce de la recherche
le pitch la recherche c'est un petit
gars on attend le baiser de sa mère de
l'asseoir dans la nuit et comme on ne
vient pas suffisamment à son gré il va
dans les bals pour se consoler voilà ou
alors le pitch la recherche alors le
pistolet de bouquins 10 ans et ma vie
bilan globalement très positif est ce
que je peux apporter une toute petite
mais molle ou ce qui est positif c'est
pas ma vie c'est là aussi c'est la vie
ma vie elle aurait pu être mieux
je serai ému et je serai gide je serai
aragon je serai extrêmement satisfaits
n'étant pas un bond récent pas
chateaubriand n'étant pas gide
je suis un peu mélancolique mais ce qui
est bien c'est la vie c'est la vie c'est
la vie
en tous les cas ça donne l'occasion
d'être avec vous là spécialement pour
écrire ça c'était bien alors en tous les
cas vous n'avez jamais eu besoin de psy
voix non
vous avez survécu à la psychanalyse au
nouveau roman vous avez qu à jean paul
sartre
ah ça c'est pas mal quand même non bah
oui il y en a qui ont laissé des plumes
alors il ya une autre façon de pitch est
votre livre j'en sais il ya deux grandes
interrogations dans la vie l'une au
début c'est que faire et l'autre c'est à
la fin qu'ai-je fait c'est une façon de
le raconter aussi
alors écoutez je vois qu'il ya ici il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont 20 ans et si je
vous dois quelque chose
thierry et je vous dois beaucoup c'est
que probablement vous m'avez fournit des
lecteurs plus jeune que ce que j'avais
quand j'écrivais au plaisir de dieu
j'avais sûrement les lecteurs que j'aime
beaucoup mais qui était sûrement
beaucoup plus âgés et peut-être que les
gens qui glissent matin sont un peu plus
jeunes grâce en partie au fait c'est
vrai dans ce qui veut dire sans faire de
fausse modestie
c'est vrai que cette émission est
beaucoup regardé par les jeunes et
qu'elle vend des livres est alors temps
jamais à temps vous savez eh bien je
trouvais ça très dur
vraiment je trouve ça très dur et
pourtant j'avais des avantages énormes à
20 ans j'étais fonctionnaire
j'étais entre à l'école normale j'étais
payé ma carrière est engagé au bon
en plus quand j'avais 20 ans je crois
que le taux de chômage était de 0,4 pour
cent
c'est à dire que ce qu'on voulait faire
on trouve et où il ya métier vous deviez
et bien malgré ça j'ai trouvé ça très
dur d'avoir 20 ans il y avait une phrase
célèbre de nos agents vous connaissez
vous permettra à personne de dire que 20
ans et le plus bel âge de la vie
eh bien c'était vrai montant alors je
vous jure que je ne cherche pas à faire
la démagogie
ouais mais je trouve que les gens qui
ont 20 ans aujourd'hui ont vraiment
beaucoup de courage parce qu'ils sont
très gais semble très est très très
confiants et moi je trouve ça épatant
alors votre précédent livre gens simples
et voyez comme en danse et ça commençait
déjà autour du cercueil d'un ami à c'est
déjà un peu vous commentez d'une
certaine façon vous savez c'est vrai et
vous savez quelque fois on me dit alors
qu'est ce que tu penses de ton livre et
je dis je ne sais pas je n'ai encore vu
personne et c'est les gens qui lisent
les livres qui m'apprennent équipe tout
à coup c'est vrai ce livre ci tourne
quand même beaucoup autour de nous un
mail envoyé à l'annonceur n'est pas bon
l'annnonce de ma mort est très mature et
oui mais enfin bon moi excusez moi je
suis si vous faites ça pourquoi vous il
reste avec nous et non c'est moi et moi
ces vols puns et valbonne enfin le livre
précédent s'était déjà à l'enterrement
et je sais pas peut-être que
quelques-uns d'entre vous se souviennent
d'un livre qui s'appelait la douane le
maire et je mourrai à la première part
alors évidemment c'est un problème qui
m'a un peu fait pour conjurer le sort
sur moi c'est peut-être aussi une charte
n
vous avez honte traitement j'apparais
beaucoup comme lui fais de champion un
peu benêt du bonheur je veux crétins qui
trouve que tout va bien
il ya aussi sûrement une grande
mélancolie l'on est dans mes livres
depuis le début mai une mélancolie à ses
gains jeudi à tous les gens qui sont ici
profiter de jean d'ormesson parce
qu'elle n'a pas beaucoup des comme ça
moi j'en profite au maximum si je
pouvais l'avoir 5 3 par an et près d'1 5
3 bat d'abord merci thierry je voudrais
ajouter que profiter de moi que vous
n'avez plus pour si longtemps et ensuite
étiré je voulais vous demander est ce
que je pourrais avoir ici un rond de
serviette
oui mes pantoufles mais attendez parce
que quand j'arrive là évidemment j'ai
l'impression de mieux chez moi mais
coutadeur d'ancash non que je voulais
remplacer ben si vous pouvez bien alors
le contenu du bouquin alors il ya cette
phrase vous vous dites
la vie c'est les livres les femmes et
les bains de mer et gaston gallimard lui
disaient les bandes marne les femmes et
alors c'est quand même pas une réponse
est patent vrai alors c'est pas tant les
bains de mer bon vous voyez ce que c'est
ça veut dire pas seulement les balles
mais bon les courses en voiture litanie
les îles grecques les voyages
sueur voilà je suis mademoiselle et
voilà bon et puis les femmes
alors ça c'est bien parce que on m'a
souvent dit à la télévision pas de
tunnel pas que tunnel sur les femmes
on n'en parle pas pour le mot prignon
n'en parle pas et les livres alors on
peut en parler on ne parle évidemment
des thèmes qui sont des thèmes
or mais sonia come on come on dira
bientôt le privilège de la naissance le
sens de l'histoire parler du big bang
c'est très très riche si les thèmes
souvent abordés mais cette fois c'est
vrai qu'il ya une petite mélancolie ya
quelque chose d'un petit peu comme ça
quoi
la fêlure dans le cristal le thème de la
naissance j'ai pensé que au fond bon
j'ai été élevé ou est-ce que j'ai été
élevé j'ai été levée dans un château
bah oui eh ben c'est mon trotskisme
hameau ya des gens qui ont un passé
trotskiste bombe a très très bien
pourquoi les emmerder avec ça
éternellement
et ben moi non plus on va pas m'emmerder
l'ordre et éleveurs à château est tout à
fait plus trop ce qu'ils lui en reste qu
est chaude du château il en reste
quelque chose d'aussi mais on essaie
d'oublier tout ça voilà dans le bilan ou
fait finalement de la vie d'une certaine
façon j'en sais comment s'est guère plus
sans parfum quant à yvon quoi un nom
alors si c'était à refaire
si c'était à refaire je ne leur ferai
pas un non franchement j'ai trouvé ça
épatant j'ai vraiment beaucoup aimé la
vie est si bon génie ou un mauvais génie
me disais voilà tu peux recommencer je
crois pas que ça commencerait
et william ont abordé différents mais
c'est vite quoi il aurait été impossible
aussi la machine mais c'est vite la
messe et bus alors qu'est-ce que vous
changeriez si votre vie était à refaire
imaginons vous acceptez de la refaire
vous changeriez quoi vous feriez les
mêmes les mêmes folies les mêmes
terrains en chambre ouais je tâchais
peut-être de rencontrer un peu plus tôt
[Rires]
ça vous allait survivre à votre mort
parce que vous avez restera postérité
non la postérité
oui alors vous savez j'y crois plus beau
ah bon je pense que la postérité une
facette une idée de l'avenir
eh bien je crois que cette idée de
l'avenir appartient au passé
vous savez pourquoi un peu à cause de
vous un peu à cause de la télévision la
télévision est une formidable machine à
éclairer mais la télévision est aussi
une machine à oublier quand on ne passe
plus à la télévision les autres passent
et tout ça fait que on est balayé et
c'est très difficile je crois que se
dire que l'on restera dans la postérité
avec toute cette masse d'informations
d'image d'événements qui roule sur le
monde c'était facile autant de flaubert
ou jose mourinho ne ferait on fera des
émissions romain soir t
moi je vous ferai les émissions hommage
vous promet peut-être du mal on dira
qu'ils cessent de la valla vous êtes
très fort si vous avez j'arrive à faire
ce bouquin là sans parler de vous en
fait oui alors vous savez gérer un malin
il ya une différence à gleason politique
c'est que eux disent toujours nous
sommes transparents oui moi je ne suis
par trans pas du tout non mais à une
époque où votre ami jean marie rouart
raconte ses coucheries à montparnasse g
c'est terrible d'ailleurs oui alors ça
vous a pas donné un petit peu l'idée
vous d'aller un peu plus loin dans les
confidences alors redit tout ouais moi
je n'ai pas grand chose non mais
d'ailleurs quand on relit les articles
quand on relit les articles ont été
écrits sur vous on s'aperçoit vous êtes
toujours méfier terriblement des
journalistes parce que vous laissait
rien paraître
vous devez vous méfier des biographes
parce qu'une fois que vous serez plus là
les mecs qui vont fouiller dans vos
papiers pour essayer mais savoir c'est
que tu devais me faire à l'idée qu'il
puisse y avoir une biographie mois et
qu'on cherche dans ma vie ça mais devant
gma ne comptent chaque pas trop de moi
près la même
même si vous vous détruisez toutes les
lettres par exemple de femme c'est une
supposition que vous avez reçu demandé à
ces femmes à qui vous en avez écrit
détruire ouvre le tour du tournoi le
tunnel à vous faites un hommage sur arte
et c'est tout riendeau
d'accord alors jma il ya des choses
qu'on sait pas mais par exemple si je
suis très curieuse genre est ce que par
exemple ce réalisme est-ce que vous avez
déjà fait l'amour en costume
d'académicien par exemple non non jamais
elles sont souvent même mais même
j'aurais pu par exemple le faire sans
habits d'académiciens mais un bicorne
sur l'or
non non non est-ce que vous avez déjà
pratiqué des jeux érotiques avec l'épée
jean ah non vous allez n'hésitez à
bonsecours enfin vous expliquer sans
arrêt que vous êtes au bout du chemin
gens nous on veut pas le croire bien
entendu on pense que ce livre n'est
destiné qu'à vous faire aimer encore
plus si c'est possible
puis qui aura après alors encore plein
d'autres c'était bien c'était vraiment
bien c'était vraiment super bien mais
quand même pour conjurer le sort on va
passer à votre oraison funèbre est
patent voici durée
[Applaudissements]
ah la la
genre genre jeunot nous occuper jeannot
janon le réac 1 j'ai déjà mon la
thrombine comme on l'appelait étouffée
dans son sommeil par un glock terreux
c'est une sommité
mais c'est aussi un père un grand père
et même un arrière-grand-père 1 que nous
pleurons ce soir consiste à dieu jamot
étouffé par tonglet à présent je vais
demander à gilbert les le frère des deux
genoux un des deux venir nous parler de
cet ami de ses frères donc gilbert je
vais te demander de venir dire que tu un
peu vieux lui aussi alors je me mets
aussi monsieur le curé mais bien est
dehors alors dans le micro les jeux
barre alors alors alors alors alors
alors mon gâteau
je n'ai jamais su te dire que je t'aime
mais aujourd'hui 108 août qui arriverait
potes
j'ai envie de te tenir les jus oui
j'adore je t'aime tu vois tu aurais dû
mourir plus tôt pour me l'entendre dire
avec 80 ans bombail 80 piges l'été le
turc impact appétit commun on est avec
tout ce que tu t'es foutu dans la gueule
tout au long de ta vie te protège pas
non plus qu'ils étaient quand même la
moindre des choses
enfin alors donc quand je termine donc
lui alors donc seigneur jésus marie
prévenus et georgette prend soin de lui
à et surtout garde le prétoire pas de
blaye n'en veut plus pas de résurrection
merci gilbert versi longwy les jeunots
un teint du les messages d'amour qui lui
envoient j'ai à mon amour
[Musique]
waouh quand tu t'en part de nos coeurs
comme ça qui nous causent bien des
emmerdements
voilà une petite horizon fines herbes
que j'ai fait pour janot 1 jean
d'ormesson voilà tout exercice par les
échos
[Applaudissements]
merci via lomé merci beaucoup à vous
aurez tout ce soir je n'en fais pas le
prendre comme ça ces gens vous avez bien
lu
[Applaudissements]
vous devez bien manger bien tenu dans
giallo merveilleux jean d'ormesson
1 tu utilises et ta notoriété pour
séduire je crois que me celui-ci a vu
des femmes
ouais pour être connu ouais et ensuite
je me suis servi de ce que j'étais connu
pour avoir des femmes à jean d'ormesson
as-tu consommé des substances
aphrodisiaques
hélas pas suffisamment
[Applaudissements]
jean d'ormesson as-tu pêcher en
accomplissant l'acte d'amour sans
volonté de procréer
c'est ce qu'il faut dire la vérité
bah au jugement dernier oui jean
d'ormesson
as-tu pêcher à la mouche à la bouffe
jean d'ormesson
as tu envie d'une jeune cousine vraiment
dégueulasse oui secret défense jean
d'ormesson
as-tu plus durant son existence à la
communauté homosexuelle
grâce à dieu
oui comment je me rappelle que saisi
racontant d'entre nous est entre nous
non moi je ne voudrais pas ruiner d'un
coup tout le capital de sympathie que je
me suis attirée je ne suis pas
homosexuel mais évidemment j'ai beaucoup
plus à les homosexuels qui ont été les
amis très chers à moi que j'ai beaucoup
aimé et quelques fois j'ai été obligé de
courir un peu dans la salle de bain et
moto2 ou autant de la cuisine ça s'est
arrêté là
jean d'ormesson as tu regardé tf1 le
samedi soir
il m'est même arrivé de regarder
thalassa
il est arrivé le tout regarder jean
d'ormesson
as tu déjà eu envie de te suicider
je me suis toujours arrêtée sur cette
pente parce que je pense que le suicide
ratée est une chose très ridicule
jean d'ormesson as tu déjà cru que dieu
n'existait pas pire quelques fois je me
suis allé jusqu'à croire qu'il existait
jean d'ormesson as-tu commis le péché de
mensonges en répondant à ces questions
oui bien sûr je teste menti j'en appelle
à l'assistance
l'enfer ou le paradis parfait
[Musique]
j'accueille jean d'ormesson
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jean d'ormesson mesdames messieurs
bonsoir
bisous un bisou à vie
[Applaudissements]
ameganvi tous ses disques vert c'est un
coup de m
nous aussi on aime bien sûr ça va gens
ça va bien heureux de vous voir dans
cette forme éblouissante
je n'ose même pas dire votre âge on peut
dire votre je suis sans eric gellé moi
j'ai peur d'être le grand père de tout
le monde mais vous êtes génial 80 ans
alors qu'est ce que je fais catherine
enfin vous dit du bien de moi
catherine barma me demande que vous
changer de place oui là je la place
d'isabelle mergault qu'on m'a dit de
m'asseoir entre pierre et isabelle
savait pas c'est très dur de prendre ma
place
non elle danse et en plus j'ai embrassé
pierre bien gens vous allez passer un
bon été très bon c est ce qu on supporte
un vous avez passé un été avec coo
éducation
qu'est-ce que savoir s'il veut passer
l'hiver genre est-ce qu'on supporte la
canicule quand on est immortel ah oui ça
le froid une chose mais qu une partie
n'y a pas de problème ça va
alors voilà gens vous êtes de retour
parmi nous et j'en suis ravi parce que
ça vous fait un livre luxueux dernier si
vous finissez toujours par revenir quand
même pourquoi oui c'est honteux c'est
quand vous voyez un super écrire c'est
si facile était un peu à testament bilan
et puis je fais comme la castafiore je
fais mes adieux
et puis il revient bouzid écrire c'est
difficile ne pas écrire c impossible
voilà excédent vous venez d'écrire est
divisible ne pas écrire un peu si belle
formule très belle forme
venez en est ravi alors cette fois vous
publié chez robert laffont
un livre qui s'appelle une fête en
larmes très beau les bons c'est ce qu'on
appelle un oxymore laurent et voilà
c'est de la rhétorique la force
tranquille voix l'a fait gentiment la
revoilà de 20 une nuit très clair voilà
un amour et le goal molle un oxymore
demi molle c'est le père d'amy oxymore
symbole alors le pitch du blocage ag le
faire le pitch c'est un écrivain qui
reçoit une jeune journaliste qui vient
l'interviewer elle a 20 ans elle sait
rien c'est un peu bécassine faut dire
les choses et lui évidemment ici à jour
il sait tout puisque c'est vous alors ce
rendez vous qui devait durer une heure
ou deux va durer pas moins de neuf
heures pause déjeuner comprise et le
vieil écrivain qu'elle vient interviewer
va lui raconter sa vie c'est à dire
votre vie romancée votre vie rêvée dans
l'esprit de ce que aragon appelé le
mentir vrai qu'on sait jamais si c'est à
dire assez énervante c'est un peu prompt
pour brouiller les pistes
cette force au brunei pis vous êtes fort
on sait pas on ne sais pas moi même je
ne sais plus je raconte ma vie mais je
n'invente réellement en même temps il se
trouve que l'écrivain aux questions vous
a connu la grand mère de la jeune fille
alors là c'est parti vous parlez de
votre enfance de votre famille du
château il ya des choses extraordinaires
pourtant vous avez parlé de ce château a
parlé beaucoup au plaisir de dieu ça a
commencé avec ça mais bon alors vous
dites nous étions réactionnaire la vie
était comme elle était dans les siècles
pas
c'est l'avenir nous intéressait peu
c'est une vie de lenteur plus tourné
finalement effectivement vers le passé
que vers la layette surtout que rien ne
change ouais ouais voilà et moi ce que
j'ai aimé c'est que les choses changent
ouais c'est vrai alors vous dit une
chose c'est qu'à l'époque vous dites on
était chrétien ont été intimement
persuadé que tous les hommes étaient
frères mais de là à croire qu'ils
étaient égaux c'était quand même autre
chose quoi il y avait un ordre des
choses ailleurs des choses et nous
étions au sommet voilà voilà
vous racontez vos amours une léa et une
marine et anne je vais en amérique je
suis professeur à la mairie et je tombe
sur une jeune juive qui sort du ghetto
de varsovie et alors les a vécu là
dedans a échappé à la shoah est arrivé
en amérique à la suite d' aventure
extraordinaire et je tombe amoureux
d'elle et malheureusement je rencontre
une autre jeune femme marie et je
découvre peu à peu que mari son frère
était non seulement collabos non
seulement vichyste mais a servi dans
l'armée allemande
sous le lit forme allemand et a été
fusillé à la libération
alors bon vous voyez à à travers ma vie
à un braconnier le 20e siècle
c'est plus pouvant table est un simple
pouvant table le fait n'est si ce
sinistre j'ai calculé que il devait y
avoir dans le livre dit il va y avoir
entre 100 et 200 millions de mort par
violences
eh bien je crois qu'un à plutôt 300
millions avec la shoah
ecoute-moi centration les goulags la
chine le soudan le pôle potes
mantes 1 j'ai lu ment c'est le siècle
des idéologies genre bien sûr on va vous
raconter vos voyages
vous racontez vos premiers livres au
plaisir de dieu qui n'allait plus de
modestie etc ce qui m'a toujours oui il
vous dit d'ailleurs effectivement vous
avez pas de succès un jour et qu'il est
même un bouquin qui s'appelle au revoir
et merci hein et puis vous savez ce que
c'est ouais on retombe et j'ai fait un
bouquin sur un empire l'imaginaire peut
donc l'étudier
c'était une espèce de canulars
universitaire qui était la gloire de
l'empiré et et ça faisait huit cents
pages je lui ai apporté chez grasset qui
a été pouvant t'es qu'un pas vous
publiez j'ai importé chez gallimard et
il a fait ça cent mille exemplaires
voilà voilà comment ça se passe voilà
alors votre bouquin si vous vous dites
c'est un roman mais quand votre
intervieweuse page 235 vous demande ce
que vous êtes en train d'écrire vous
dites une espèce de machin oui c'est un
truc
oui parce que il est vrai que quand je
commence le livre je suis d'ici dans la
conversation
l'intervieweuse mais dans la réalité je
me disais je ne vais plus écrire des
livres
et puis au fur et à mesure que je parle
avec elle
eh ben mon livre est en train de se
faire et quand le quand la conversation
du fini eva le livre est fini aussi
alors pouvoir et de l'interview dans ce
livre dit que pour vous l'interview est
un est un supplice parce que vous
refusez de parler de votre vie privée
bridge je parle souvent de moi même mais
jamais de ma vie privée oui c'est vrai
mais c'est vrai qu'on sait pas en fait
moi je le sais parce que je vous connais
vous savez pas ce que vous savez tout
mais j'en parle très peu
1 j'ai beaucoup aimé michel vaujour les
silences du chêne bourg ge et on
n'essaye pas de temps à en parler de
l'amour gens très bien de mieux en mieux
moi je trouve que vous êtes vraiment à
chaque fois alors là pour le coup c'est
pas la mort en soie court encore après
les femmes sait plus très bien pour vite
l'amour c'est ce qu'on a trouvé de mieux
pour rendre la vie supportable
bien sûr de quoi est-ce qu'on s'occupe
d'autre
de quoi s continue très séduisant juin à
mais il est allé je comprends très bien
il a doublé en plus non mais ça je m'en
fous
ouais saisir le 8 la une des phrases
formidable dit au sujet de la vieillesse
vieillir c'est seul moyen de ne pas être
mort mais c'est vrai c'est vrai mais oui
c'est ce que j'ai fait alors vous parlez
de la mort vous dites la vie n'est belle
que parce que nous mourrons c'est
insupportable
il a dit des conneries aussi des votants
alors il immortel il ya un truc dans
votre bouquin moi qui m'a fait rire
c'est vraiment j'adore ce bouquin mais
quand vous dites
tu sais il fit une auto interview donc
il dit à la jeune fille qui
l'interviewent qui vient dans le
magazine comme ça et il lui dit je vous
ennuie avec toutes mes histoires et tout
non messieurs d'ormesson au nom vous
m'ennuyer pas faisait tellement
intéressant ça s'appelle enfin à la
chine fort complet - c'est un peu
clinquant mais c'est lui qui fait des
questions les réponses tu as fait ça
reste déçu alors voilà alors il ya deux
types de réactions par rapport au
bouquin vous avez vu il ya ceux qui
disent y'en a marre on n'en peut plus
genre beigbeder dans voici qui dit c'est
la énième compile d'ormesson
c'est vrai c'est un peu comme comme dave
c'est à dire que vanina il le dit pamela
vanina de d'ormesson
c'est chateaubriand quoi c'est à dire
qu'il n'en peut plus il ya télérama
aussi qui dit jean d'ormesson ressasse
ses poncifs sur venise sur la chute du
mur de berlin paresseuse dissertation de
causeur monde donc ça c'est ça c'est
fait c'est fait c'est réglé et puis on
en parlera aux plus grands parents plus
gadget
tapie gadgets ja ja eysines dans l'ope
s'y entraînent dans le point il ya le
nourricier alors là il vous trouve
épatant délicieux que les gens ne se
lasse pas de vieux os finalement
qu'est-ce qui vous rend tellement
sympathique c'est vos yeux c'est quoi il
est complètement séduisant il est jamais
que je sorte en vous il est il est
intelligent il est liffré ille et
ravissant cet homme est ravissant
totalement de mails adore velador voilà
marié avec lui et moi demain il demande
en mariage
eh ben il peut être jean pierre et
fléchard étaient moins ce que vous
pouvez jeter témoins de jéhovah je peux
mais perso j'en vous êtes une une star
de l'académie donc on va vous faire
l'interview star academy français
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors on va comparer un petit peu la
star ac et et l'académie à la star
academy l'académie française est ce qui
est de la meuf à la cades est bien
évidemment il ya la main bas sont courts
c'est même moi qui l'a fait entrer cette
union sonar un mur sonore via ce 1 vous
rappelez bien c'est moi qui ai fait
entrer la première fois mal à kalemie
vous vous rappelez qu'il y avait toute
la presse pas seulement parisienne mais
française et mondiale et à la fin on m'a
demandé alors qu'est ce qui a changé à
l'académie et j'ai répondu
maintenant il y aura deux toilettes sur
lui nuire a écrit messieurs et sur
l'autre marguerite yourcenar et depuis
j'ai vu d'autres
il ya eu romilly et vêtements madame de
roguennic est une merveille ya florence
delay il ya notre secrétaire perpétuel
de la meuf passer la main là tu vois et
pas que des tons là la star ac et
l'académie française c'est la même chose
est ce qu'il ya des couples qui se sont
formés à l'académie franz la sueur y en
avoir mais défaire recevrez donc sérieux
bien sûr de ne devoir n'ai pas les
détails
est ce que à l'académie française comme
un astarac vous pouvez perdre votre
place à tout moment ah non
impressionnant pour toujours impossible
ouais ça on ne peut pas juste il ya des
ombres alors ils peuvent pas être viré
puis sa vie il ya des embrouilles entre
académiciens des embrouilles
mais oui souvent ils se détestent et
intel bord ils sont tous habillés pareil
ouais on me reconnaît pas quels choix
est-ce que ça parle beaucoup dans le dos
des autres comme à la star ac oui ces
gens c'est loin vous avez une salle de
sport bah non non on salle csa
non non on pourra vous pourrez est-ce
qu'il ya beaucoup de prétendants et peu
d'élus oui ah bah oui tout le monde
ouais tout le monde veut y aller tout le
monde joue le jeu
c'est qu'ils m'ont reçue nous sommes
quarante n'y a pas de prochain y'a pas
trop ça y'a pas de prochain qui meurt il
faut atteindre cannage qu'on ne souhaite
pas mais il en mourra a sûrement très
vite il en meurt trois qu'ils avaient un
prof de diction à l'académie française
je vais vous donner des cours de diction
serge alors est-ce que vous pouvez vous
exclure les uns les autres en votant non
non ah non on peut exclure on peut
exclure les candidats ouais mais il va
cogner c'est fini alors est-ce que c'est
comme à la star ac il ya toujours un
noir un conte un belge une bible mot une
doux et un nul pour que le monde entier
puisse se reconnaître non alors un coup
sûrement un bel jada c'est une bimbo
avait eu un prix égal est une des oui
oui un nul est-ce que c'est comme à la
star actuellement nous oublié au bout de
deux ans à l'académie française non ah
non non pas du tout non ça ne dure
longtemps puisqu'on victimes mortelles
ça va l'immortel en est tranquille je
viens par crois que vous êtes vraiment
une mortelle non mais vous savez la
définition c'était on est immortel pour
la durée notre vie et après on se change
en fauteuil
jean d'ormesson
à ces publié chez robert laffont m
messieurs
[Musique]